on behalf of the court I take note of
your solemn commitment and I
now invite the president of the
amm swell commission on the sale of
line to speak
royal highness sir the president of
the court
sir the prime minister on the right
taken  foot on the ground badly all
alone moreover finished union auderghem crime
one which to my mind we do not have to
play now he had only constitutes a solid
with the values ​​democracy hzds or not
larks of world in the nose imaging
all police mind and sweety  balance of
opinions ian richardson of human rights
and the we are guardians of the british to
huy responsibility to give in to deliver
kandadji bigotry dozens of chargers
to him wished respect in modena list of
articles we start investing there first
we say die for the  united states of our
ping continues the story of how we want
from senso isoroy du credit n'guessan
previous continental titles
democracy we may be proud to what it
industry and it is it and  charge
individual right to life the liberty
equality avowed menad even of right to
fail jasse working as a challenge of duty to
fight for social justice of duty to
promote peas inside
side on the stock exchange in china
[Music]
bergessio
hsinchu iso philosophy of days of summer
is  right his way schoenaerts richie
rich wilson there were shrill cries
and our teenagers placed in the
world we you find saxon mezine 7
fright night world title of protection
of personal data
ladies and gentlemen judges
today taking an oath before
you who represent  law and the rule
of law
today we take an oath to
respect and protect our European values
today we take an oath on
all that we hold most dear and
we take a charming oath to work
for each citizen  European whether he
comes from a small or a large country
in the east or the west of the north or the south
because europe only advances if we
have are all so in
national interests are reconciled within a
wider european interest there is
only one european union
when we are united we are all
stronger stronger on the
international stage stronger against
climate change stronger to
protect people  interests of our citizens
the moore
that we have just pronounced sets the
bar very high for each and every
one of us have
determined to take up this challenge
this commission will comply with a code
of conduct that is more demanding than ever in
courses intended to guarantee  that we
are serving the general interest of
europeans we want to be a
more transparent and more responsible commission in order
to win
the trust of european citizens more and more each day
because it is to them
that europe belongs say mansion
europass gruss d'  offers therefore sesame
benzid and run like to business english
continence of a rare violence at the foot
charest now we were a president
dir  hams and what is big breasts of
gab violence mam annoyance of each
respective function one drains kindle the
kindle kindle disney dream soviet union
to aurelie mme frigon planet swing
in asthma the nati has been rigorously the
leak in the form of a  system so-called acts
of acts of purchase of families grazioso
digg-like hamas n'a atheists a to man
we had to be fatal of the world sushi
taxi or byron d'atr but if dan a
democrat in the vaccine and philosophy
a vein euros by  hunt fayote or
danette
oudart trots in the dangerous
European study and these will have
voting excavations to be combined with cycles
at the jafs 6-10 match sheet ten
freundschaft saw big wolf than
himself
heinz french freund m durand said
flight  bag is good that a phase where the ong
goal or drar highfive is synonymous everything
find that in usa fall for the iphone
the itouch ask the hunted the continued
fayyad typhoid the stone this
commission matches in anaheim ducks dan
won't do michel bastos who have morfled
either black fun on the legs under an area
of ​​ten meters
gross brushed against a dozen his
daughter emma s libar europa long live europe
language rape
[Applause]
spinning from agde to president zine
Royal Highness Madam President,
Ladies and Gentlemen, Members of the
Commission, Excellencies, Ladies and
Gentlemen, I declare this
solemn audience adjourned and invite you to
meet us at the reception which
awaits us in the Salle des Pas Perdus.
belly
i don't know
you english
m